I've heard you say that those with cancer should not take glutathione supplements
because it could cause the cancer to grow. I forget the specific mechanism at the moment.
So the mechanism of action of glutathione and cancer is that glutathione
to glutathione is you're made, you make glutathione in every cell. Your mitochondria
bakes glutathione actually recycles glutathione. Glutathione is your made cellular antioxidant.
You have other antioxidant superoxide. This retakes catalysts. You have other pathways for
antide, for dealing with oxidative stress. So understand what oxidative stress is oxidative stress
is caused by toxins caused by chronic infections, creates an oxidative stress environment
of a cell and a cell can only take so much oxidative stress before the cell
could die, could cause cell lysis, cell death, pathology to the cell, the cell dies.
So other bad things oxidative stress can cause. It can damage or organelles of the cell.
It can damage cell membranes. It can damage the nucleus and it can be the cause of cancer.
So oxidative stress can be a cause of cancer. It's the number one cause of cancer is oxidative stress.
However, what's a person has cancer? So step X, all right, to prevent cancer is to help support
the elimination of oxidative stress, which is the elimination of oxidative stress on a cellular
basis is the role of glutathione. It's the role of your other antioxidant systems,
the catalase, superoxide, dispatase, et cetera. So either excess oxidative stress or
or impaired glutathione antioxidant production can be the cause of cancer or at least a cause of
cancer. But once a person has cancer, a cancer cell is replicated quickly. It's not
replicating healthy mitochondria. Therefore, it's not making good antioxidants. It's not
have good glutathione production. So a cancer cell itself is already a very highly oxidative
stress. And remember, there's a threshold. So there's a there's a limit of oxidative stress that will
tip over a cell and cause cell death. So a cancer cell is already near that threshold. They're very
close to that threshold of lethal death due to oxidative stress. So think of a line and a graph.
And a cancer cell is much higher than a normal cell as far as the level of oxidative stress that's
going on internally in that cell. So most cancer therapies, including those that are that you are
doing, which is if you're doing different herbs, can cause oxidative stress to a cancer cell and it
causes lethal death at the cancer cell, be 17 to to seac to to fenmentozole, to either
erected to it'll go on and on. Everything that I have you guys on is oxidative to cancer cells.
Now the nice thing about natural therapies is they're oxidative to cancer cells but not to healthy cells.
So they spare healthy cells and they can kill cancer cells. So is chemotherapy, chemotherapy is an
oxidizing agent to tip over cancer cells. Unfortunately, chemotherapy doesn't spare healthy cells
so it can damage healthy cells. But every therapy out there is an oxidative stress therapy, every
cancer therapy is oxidative stress therapy, high dose vitamin C is an oxidative stress therapy.
So if you're going to take glutathione while you're doing an ox a different oxidative stress
therapies, you are kind of you're kind of negated the whole purpose. You are taking glutathione.
You could be you could be causing cancer cells to survive the therapy that you're trying to use
to kill them. So therefore typically a cancer patient does not use glutathione. That's the mechanism.
Now I want to get your question. Would it be okay to take NAD as a way to naturally boost
glutathione levels to help with detoxification? And if so what with the dosage you recommend I'm
guessing that age 70 by glutathione levels are pretty low. So no, I don't think you should take NAD.
So they continue to mind. The oxide NAD supplements are not first of all really meant to boost
glutathione levels. NAD really boosts nitric oxide levels which is a totally different mechanism.
So nitric oxide functions in a way to boost a whole different pathway.
It boosts vascular endothelial growth factor which if you have a hard tumor and you're not in
complete remission, you could actually be causing your body to make new vessels into that tumor
thereby allowing the tumor to be fed and to grow more rapidly. So you don't want to take any
nitric oxide boosters when you have a cancer going on. Now NAD works in other ways too to help
mitochondria. Secondary effect helps glutathione levels NAD also helps nitric oxide in the way that it
helps with stimulate smooth muscle relaxation in the endothelial cells which is your vascular system.
So nitric oxide can help relax the smooth muscles of the endothelial lining and cause blood pressure
to go down. So there's huge benefits to nitric oxide but if a person has a growing cancer you don't
want to use nitric oxide because one of its huge things is to increase vascular endothelial growth
factor which is super beneficial if you have cardiovascular issues but not so much if you have
cancer which is the catch 22 of let's say you have both you know very common people have cardiovascular
issues but they also have cancer or in the case of the person asking a question they have
live disease but they have cancer live disease. If you only had live disease I'd definitely be
putting you on glutathione but if you have cancer too you're trying to help your body deal with
live disease you could actually be feeding you know keeping a live cancer cell so there's danger
to that. Take NAD that can be very helpful for live disease or cardiovascular issues or high blood
pressure issues but it can also cause a cancer to grow. So some of the things that are good for
cardiovascular people or good for for live disease people or chronic infection people are not good
for cancer patients and that's the danger of you know take say this nicely getting advice
from a practitioner who doesn't truly understand cancer. Most people that come to me are getting advice
from a practitioner and they're on supplements and they shouldn't be on those supplements given the
diagnosis of cancer but just because I am a practitioner this is what I would put you on because
you have cancer so you should be on glutathione because you really need to decrease oxidative stress
because oxidative stress is the cause of cancer so we're going to get you on glutathione but you
already have cancer so you don't want to go on glutathione so not understanding that peace can be
very deadly so you know don't do that you'd be careful where you're getting your advice certainly
you don't want it to be from Instagram influencers so and it better be a practitioner that understands
your diagnosis is taking that into consideration understanding these things or they should be going
this is not my specialty you should talk to somebody who that's more their specialty